Okay, is the right program stomach flu?
A good thing to run if you think stomach is upset.
Upset is an virus.
Yeah, there's multiple flu programs.
There's cold and flu oncoming.
There's, oh gosh, there's half a dozen flu programs
at least there's the viral complex program
program which goes through multiple different viruses.
So people are going to respond differently
to different frequencies.
So we're just going to try different programs
and see which one works the best for you.
Historically, I've heard the best comments
from the viral complex program
and the cold and flu oncoming program.
So certainly give those a try too.
But yeah, whatever, you know, you should be using your arrive
for cold morbidity or just other issues
that you have going on.
You should be running different programs
as you see fit to do.
So you have other things going on.
Other people have your family up other things going on.
Make sure you go to your right as your first
light of defense against
and just to go to everything.
So I know people get used to running my program all the time.
You know, I turn on my favorite night
running my program.
But if I feel like I have something going on
or run a different program, I work.